Hi everyone it's Jerry. This is a game from the
2004 Reykjavik Rapid between Magnus Carlsen
and Garry Kasparov. This was their very first
encounter. Carlsen still 13 years old and
an International master at the time... 2484
fide rating. And Kasparov having a rating
of 2831 at the time. So, let's dive right
in here, again Carlsen on the white end playing
d4. Kasparov responding d5. And we get right
into the Cambridge Springs defense, which
is denoted by the move queen to a5 which is
doing a few things: first and foremost getting
out of a pin, secondly placing white in a
pin, and you might as well start to already
view the queen doing a third thing, namely
functioning laterally. Because at any moment
there can be this capture d takes c and in
many instances it could be netting black some
material. I'll touch on that in a little bit
from now. But before I get to it, let me point
out that if this happens to be an opening
you play as white or black, there is a neat
little trap, I guess you could say, that could
come about. But it shows itself with a slightly
tweaked move order, so let me touch on that
very quickly. It runs with after c4, we are
not having c6 but rather e6. Knight c3, knight
f6, bishop g5, and knight here. So we're looking
at again a similar position but, the difference
here is that the moves knight f3 and c6 are
absent. And the thing to be cautious of as
white is to resist the temptation to go ahead
and win a pawn, because you are not winning
pawn in the following way... this is actually
falling for what's known as the elephant trap
where after white takes on this square, trying
to exploit this pin, black can simply ignore
it. And it's a very very temporary queen sac...
black getting the white queen back just a
couple moves later and after the smoke has
cleared, black is simply up a knight. This
of course is not going to happen in the high-level
games, but something to certainly be aware
of should you already have this as part of
your own opening repertoire... as again white
or black. Getting back on with the actual
game, after this queen a5 move white takes
immediate action against this pin, breaking
it with knight d2 and also watching over this
e4 square, either one of these knights is
now able to watch over that e4 square. And
this is already a very important detail because
if white is just going to be running with
a very natural looking type of move such as
bishop to d3, preparing to castle, watching
over the e4 square. Black could still just
throw that knight into that e4 square, adding
more fuel to that c3 knight, pressure on the
bishop, and there is an interesting sequence
of moves if you know it gets to be too much
on the white end and white wants to remove
one of the attackers of the c3 square, with
bishop takes knight... well now we have d
takes e, which is clearing this 5th rank for
that black queen. So knight e5 is pretty much
the only move to save that bishop. And then
we kind of get into a little bit of a wacky
variation here after f6 we could have queen
to h5, g6, knight takes, pawn takes, queen
takes rook, queen takes bishop, and this is
a really weird imbalance. But, black is actually
the side that's going to stand better even
though it seems like their king is a little
bit shaky. The queen alone is not going to
be enough to disrupt that black king's position.
If we are to take it a couple moves further,
we pretty much have this situation right here
where these bishops are going to be ready
to just strike at that white king very soon.
The bishop maybe coming out to this diagonal,
the other bishop making use of this diagonal,
and the queen is a difficult piece to be chasing
off of these very weak light squares on the
white side. So again, be aware of that 3rd
detail when the queen does play to a5 here.
Again, off of the diagonal, functioning on
this one, and the lateral movement shows itself
in many variations. So, knight d2 breaking
the pin, bishop b4, persistent on this c3
point. Queen to c2, lending support. Black
castles, bishop e2, and e5. So, striking at
the white center right here with this e5 move
and at a later point looking to develop this
bishop. However, in this game that bishop
really does just sit on that c8 square for
some time. In fact, it doesn't even move until
move 29. So there's quite a bit of stuff that
goes on before this bishop moves, and well
actually that rook as well. So, the bishop
has to move before this guy can get out of
the corner. So there is an important detail
right here, and it's once again focused on
this lateral movement. The difference between
e2 and d3 is really the whole game really
because if you play here, there we go, game
over. Can you believe it? Believe it! Because,
we have the bishop hit and this bishop hit.
And there is no in between move for white
because black says no my in between move is
even stronger taking the bishop, being on
the queen and only then recapturing. And we
once again have a situation where black is
just up a minor piece. So, the difference
between bishop to d3 and bishop to e2, as
was played in the game is a very significant
one. So, e5 striking in the center, white
now fully developed. That's noted by a direct
connection between those rooks. Takes, knight
b3, hitting the queen. And when I initially
saw this, okay queen goes back to b6, when
I initially saw this I thought okay the knight
pivoted there hitting the queen and then would
be recapturing. And I guess this is maybe
a somewhat solid approach to it, not having
to cope with an isolated queen pawn type of
position which is the type of structure we
end up having to work with on the white end
here. So we'll see how that shows itself.
What's also important to note is that if in
the situation knight takes pawn was played,
and the bishop takes the knight, again be
aware of this knight pivot to the e4 square.
If queen takes, then this is big trouble.
So, white would be needing to capture with
the pawn in that instance. But, we don't have
the recapture on this square right here with
that b3 knight, but rather e takes d. And
after d takes c, bishop takes c, there we
have it isolated queen pawn. And, so this
is a dynamic advantage here for white. White
is looking to maybe press forward in the center
at some point, change the pawn structure,
and show that this lead in development that
white has is going to prove useful... prove
to be actually an advantage. So, we have a5
and then a4. This is a very typical idea to
be aware of... knights that find themselves
on b3 b6 g6 g3 are often chased away with
these rook pawns. It often becomes very difficult
for that knight to have a good reaction to
a threat when the rook pawns come down to
attack it. So, white stops that cold with
a4. And I think that this is a little bit
of an uncomfortable move to have to make,
I really do like this a5 move. After a4, because
now this is a hole... this bishop is able
to kind of just sit there, and maybe one day
one of these knights, let's say the one on
d7 can somehow make use of that square as
well. So, there is a little bit of a concession,
but the main point is to preserve this knight's
position for the time being. So, queen back
c7, functioning on this diagonal right now,
that h2 point. Rook to e1, getting it doing
something, the bishop gets kicked around,
bishop d6, and now h3 and then okay knight
to b6. Now at this point I was actually, when
I first reviewed it I was looking at g5 and
then I'm like "well where is the compensation
exactly... where is this compensation?". And
it completely slipped my mind that hey "what
do we have going on here?". This is something
I should've been thinking all the while, this
pawn is pinned and a pinned piece is a powerless
one. This could be a deadly check. In fact,
it would just be a winning shot at this very
early stage. As soon as g5 is played, just
boom! check, take check, knight blocks, grab
another pawn, the position is crumbling, the
king is dead. So, just be aware of that, that
bishop on c4. In fact, you might as well already,
in your own internal dialogue, in your own
thinking when you're playing the game... as
soon as this bishop makes the capture on c4,
you might as well just start saying "okay,
that pawn is pinned". And maybe there's a
way to be making use of it, maybe you can
be making use of this square right now. It's
not super clear where you can be doing that
in this case just yet. But definitely at this
point right here, as soon as h6 is played
you could be making use of that square one
day. Anyhow, bishop back, bishop d6, h3, knight
b6 hitting the bishop, and this is definitely
one of those positions where black has to
come up with something because it's really
a case where black is in a giant knot. Because
look at these queen side pieces, they are
just spectators, "what are they doing?". And
what is this knight doing? It's a complete
domino effect really. If this knight can't
move, this bishop can't move, and if this
bishop can't move, this rook can't do anything.
And the sad thing is that if this knight does
move, I mean it does move in the game it goes
to b6, but because of the pressure, this is
what I'm getting at, because of the pressure
that white has against this knight, it just
kind of bottles up this whole queen side,
its influence is a tremendous one. So we have
both sides basically going into a pretty big
think here. Well really Kasparov at this point,
knight b6. Because we have a couple captures
going on here. There is not just this typical
capture and then recapture stuff going on.
No, we have after bishop takes on f6, knight
takes c4, and white doesn't react to the threat
on the bishop, but rather knight to e4, counterattacking
move, centralizing the knight, hitting the
bishop, and also hitting this knight right
here. Black responds first inserting a check,
king h1 only move, and now this is where there
is maybe a slight improvement on the black
end because now it's white who really dictates
the game and obtains a very strong initiative.
And in fact throughout this whole game white
was never worse off, white was always slightly
better. And now things become even worse for
black. In the game we saw knight d6, and the
continuation was king takes bishop which is
welcoming one of these very devastating moves,
one of these discovered checks. But it's not
so devastating in this instance right here.
After knight captures on e4 we have just the
counterattacking bishop to e5, and unfortunately
black is having to work themselves back into
a pin in order to preserve that knight. The
alternative is to not play knight d6 but rather
b5, maintaining this knight's position and
I believe white would soon be having to react
to just this pawn takes bishop move. But we
don't have that, b5 was not played. The knight
actually reacts to that queen threat, knight
d6, Carlsen working himself into a discovered
attack. Knight takes, bishop back, knight
d6 and here we go. If one of the pieces is
in a pin, what do you do? You add fuel to
it, queen c5, two pieces hitting, and again
white is dictating the game from here... has
the initiative in other words. d5, throwing
punches at black, hitting at c6, vacating
d4. The knight is looking to centralize itself,
all the while these two again are still just
camping out here on the queen side, not doing
thing. So queen d7, a natural reaction to
being in a pin, get out of it. Knight d4,
more pressure on c6, and knight to f5. An
important point is this one right here. In
fact if you want to stop the video and see
what would you do in this instance right here.
Again if you'd like to pause the video, what
would be the winning continuation for white
in this position? Okay, the sequence of moves
which would absolutely kill black is just
to take the knight and then at the end of
it we're having this check and then again,
not the first time we're seeing this idea,
piling up on the pinned piece, the pinned
piece is the bishop, it's dead, and so too
will be that black king soon enough. So in
other words, c takes d, don't do it. Knight
f5 instead, d takes c, on the queen, b takes
c, knight takes pawn, white is up a pawn.
The knight is within checking distance, hitting
the rook. Things are very uncomfortable for
black. Again these guys, a couple clowns right
here on the queen side. Rook to e8 in the
meantime, rook d1, queen e6, and we have rook
f to e1 which is a very natural looking move.
It's very human-like to be making this type
of move, it's just tidying everything up,
centralizing these rooks, and now we just
have all of the white pieces functioning.
However the improvement is going to be this
move right here which is well I guess not
so human-like because it's not harmonious.
This bishop right now on that c7 square is
not protected. When there's this rook f to
e1 move, again everything is nice and cozy
here, everything is defended, the rooks guarding
one another, controlling all these central
squares. But this bishop to c7 move would
have been the more accurate thing to do. I'm
not aware of what the time constraints were,
or what the time controls were at that very
moment. But what is this move doing? It's
just adding what is now a 3rd attacker to
that a5 pawn, and if that goes we're going
to have these pawns right here, these connected
passed a and b pawns, it's going to be a very
strong thing. So, it was not played and instead
again rook f to e1. And finally, move 29,
we are having that queen bishop do something.
So it throws itself on a very good diagonal,
main light square diagonal. And now we have
the knight coming back, this fork going on
and actually even though white is up a pawn,
there is not really going to be a way to convert
it. In fact this endgame just kind of goes
to nothing right here. It gets to a position
where white really can't make use of that
extra pawn because it's in large part to these
guys being on opposite colors. Opposite colored
bishops will often translate into a draw,
and this position right here is no exception.
So we just have a lot of little logical moves
going on here, the meeting of one move threats.
Attack of the pawn, defense of the pawn, that
sort of stuff. Additionally when this bishop
was threatened right here with f6, what do
you want to do? You want to react but still
be aggressive in some way. So that's why it's
coming to that c3 square. So the rooks come
off, the rook defends, the kings improve their
position. This is an endgame, the kings need
to be doing stuff. And now the bishop is looking
to make sure this pawn doesn't get out of
control. a5, bishop back, f3, and you'll notice
that it's not by chance that we're kind of
having right here on both sides these sorts
of structures. You really don't want to be
too careless right here with let's say white
making a move like f4. I'm sure it's still
okay, but it's kind of allowing for maybe
the bishop to get on this diagonal, and maybe
the rook one day being able to get on this
2nd rank and easily converge on that g2 square.
However, if this type of structure is maintained,
the pawns on f3 and g2, and similarly g7 and
f6, both structures are combating, or taking
into account the opposing bishops and how
they can maybe be putting pressure on the
base points g7 and g2. So just a quick point
to be making. This does turn out to just be
a draw. We have rook to h1, getting out of
this pin. If there is any chance for a win
on the white end, they are needing to keep
the rooks on the board. And so that's why
we are having white throw in a check, the
king goes back, the bishop plays to c5. The
rook now has the opportunity to get to this
active 2nd rank and get behind the passed
pawn. This is the ideal placement for a rook
defending against a passed pawn, you would
like to get it behind the pawn. King goes
back to g3, defense. Rook a2, bishop b6, king
f7, rook c1, getting this pawn involved guarding
some dark squares against that white king.
Rook check, king g6, rook c6, placing the
king in a pin or that pawn in a pin, maybe
looking bishop to d4. But now black can put
pressure on this pawn right here, and white
just defends by just playing bishop to f2,
and a draw was agreed at this point. So 13-year-old
Magnus Carlsen drawing the legendary Garry
Kasparov. Really really incredible thing to
have happen. There is nothing more at this
point. I was wondering if there was something
like bishop to d4, but something as calm as
rook to a6 and there's nothing to do. This
is definitely a drawn position. But as it
was in this game, after bishop to f2 both
players agreed to a draw. So that's all for
this video. As always, I hope you got something
out of it. Take care, bye.